اسبوع رابع ينتصف من مواجهه السودان الذي
يمضي في طريق العوده نحو 500 مدنيين على
الاقل ذهبوا ضحيه النزاع المسلح فضلا عن
الاف المصابين واعداد اكبر للنازحين هنا
في جده تستمر المحادثه التمهيديه بين
القوات المسلحه السودانيه وقوات الدعم
السريع برعايه سعوديه امريكيه الخارجيه
السعوديه اكدت ان طرفي النزاع اعرب عن
تحملهما مسؤوليه وصول المساعده الانسانيه
العاجله واستعاده الخدمات الضروريه في
السودان كما شرع الطرفان في مراجعه اعلان
الالتزام بحمايه المدنيين وتيسير واحترام
العمل الانساني
وتسعى محادثات جده الى وضع جدول زمني
لمفاوضات موسعه للوصول لوقف دائم للاعمال
القتاليه كما دعت الرياض و واشنطن طرفي
النزاع في السودان الى احترام وقف اطلاق
النار الق حاليا والامتناع عن القيام باي
افعال استفزازيه تؤثر على سير المحادثات
محادثات في جده واجتماع عربي طارئ في
القاهره نتج عنه انشاء لجنه اتصال عربيه
لوقف النار في السودان تتكون من وزير
الخارجيه السعودي ونظره المصري والامين
العام للجامعه العربيه
جهود سياسيه للتهدئه تقابلها تحركات
انسانيه وحملات اجلاء مستمره تبنتها
السعوديه اخرها تقديم مساعدات انسانيه
متنوعه بقيمه 100 مليون دولار واطلاق حمله
شعبيه لمسانده الشعب السوداني
طاعه المزيد من الاخبار وال
برامج في قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على زر
الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات